welcome everybody to another exciting
titillating into the impossible
adventure with one of my longest term
friends I can't call him an old friend
he's barely older than me but he has
been a mentor an inspiration and really
set the tone for the field for many many
decades now unbelievably and uh and that
is Professor Mark kamienkowski who is
the third guest who is a professor at
Johns Hopkins University after Adam
Reese and recently Sean Carroll and so
and maybe well I don't know you don't
consider Mario olivios to still be there
right he's no longer Affiliated in any
way is he I think he's retired from
Space Telescope yeah
yeah so it is Mark haminkowski renowned
cosmologist and theorist and really uh
the reason that I'm probably having this
podcast if it wasn't for him we'll get
into that in just a minute Mark how are
you doing today and Good Old Baltimore
it's like uh in the 60s here which for
us is
a very big deal yeah yeah it's a nice
day good day for a crab cake luncheon
out there I I yeah I'm suffering through
57 degrees here in San Diego so a rare
day when it's warmer in February out
there than it is here uh so today we're
going to talk uh this episode is
tentatively titled Mark I should have
told you beforehand does cosmology need
a therapist and it's because of all
these tensions anxieties crises that
cosmology is allegedly suffering from
but before we go into that one uh that
uh which will be the substance of this
conversation I wanted to uh just bring
my readers on an adventure as you may
know if you've listened to the podcast
before seen it before I always start off
with authors and I ask them to judge
books by their covers
which is you're never supposed to do
that but what else do you have to go on
so we're going to judge this book uh
Mark it's called losing the Nobel Prize
you may have heard of it uh there are
many chapters dedicated to mark
kaminkowski but um but I talk about the
time in 1999 before I met you I knew of
you but you were still at Columbia at
the time and I was destined to meet you
when you became a professor at Caltech
and follow your career ever since and in
this particular vignette I'm describing
how uh I spoke to you the day before the
famous bicep 2 press conference which
occurred uh now it's going to be what uh
nine years ago
yeah
nine years ago on uh on St Patrick's Day
2014 where Mark was at the famous press
conference and I was not and I remember
you telling me on the phone that
there'll be other press conferences for
you Brian uh and uh but but actually the
time I want to go back to in the book is
when I first encountered you and really
the reason that you were there at that
press conference perhaps is because you
really inspired the bicep series of
experiments
um indirectly or directly via a paper
you wrote with a good friend of mine as
well as collaborator Andrew Jaffe and
lemon Wang was he a grad student
was a postdoc
it was great yeah I mean he was a
spectacular scientist he was one of the
adventures of fantastic when he's a grad
student the University of Pennsylvania
he came he got him in Colombia because
he had family reasons to want to be in
New York City
um and we wrote that paper we wrote
several others that the people still
read and pay attention to
um he was great but then he um
the reasons that he had this to come to
New York state for a postdoc were also
reasons he ate one at the remain in New
York City no and um it's not easy to
like navigate an academic career and
you're limit yourself to one small tiny
little town yeah New York has its charms
uh a lot of people have uh have
relocated from New York City but uh uh
but but we're not gonna get into those
details now I want to discuss the paper
that you guys wrote together which was
called the polarization pursuers guide
or PPG
and for me it became an another version
of an inspiring manuscript like the
version of Jay pasakov the late great
I'm fortunately Jay passed away uh just
a couple of months ago uh he wrote The
Field Guide to the stars and planets
with Donald Menzel at Harvard so he's
one of his advisors and that book
inspired me when I was 12 years old to
get my first refracting telescope and uh
become a an astronomer of some Renown
trying to follow in Galileo's footsteps
by the way today's Galileo's birthday
February 15th we're recording this happy
birthday
486 years old he looks he looks great he
looks great uh but anyway this paper
that you wrote inspired me and the
reason it was is because it was the
first time I or anybody else really
heard an inkling that one could measure
the B mode polarization of the CMB and
do it experimentally and the
extrapolation which I drew from the
paper
was that you presented a series of
graphs and we'll show those in the
b-roll here
um but you presented a series of
diagrams and those diagrams presented
how well could a given sized aperture
telescope constrain the amount of
inflationary gravitational wave energy
or the amplitude of primordial
gravitationalize and I saw that it was
almost independent of aperture size and
that really lit my fire because uh as as
many people may or may not know a
telescope's cost scales basically with
the cube of its diameter some high power
of the aperture so you were basically
telling me at that time and anyone else
who would listen that a 10 meter
diameter telescope was not necessary to
detect the primordial gravitational wave
background and that really inspired me
and I I stopped working on the projects
I was working on for Sarah Church and
she promptly fired me which then brought
me down to work with uh your friend and
my mentor Andrew so you were Stanford
before yeah I was at Stanford in 99
miserable hated working on living in
Palo Alto on a postdoc salary of thirty
two thousand dollars during the.com boom
when you know uh Google was getting
founded down the street I had no money
no prospects uh really wasn't interested
in the science that you know Sarah had
you know she had she did nothing wrong
but but I was so distracted by some of
the ideas that I'd read about in your
paper and others and really became
infatuated that I wanted to do this and
I want to study the B mode polarization
or the micro backup
and that later became the uh impetus for
the bicep experiment so bicep we can
have actually here is a replica of the
bicep lens that we use the primary
aperture lens for one of the bicep
prototypes that we built back at Caltech
where I was a postdoc and you were a
professor
and this telescope is very cheap I cut I
mean we got started with a one million
dollar uh you know Grant from president
David Baltimore I think that was one of
the Nimble features of the uh of a small
institution like Caltech in in addition
to teaching people how to weld and do
Technical College things caltech's very
Nimble I don't know if UCSD or Johns
Hopkins like that but at any rate
um that paper inspired me to go on this
adventure and since then we've had four
generations of bicep and now we've uh
we're in the third generation of of uh
the Simon's array and polar bear and
it's very similar it's on a refracting
telescope but your University co-member
colleagues class and and then of course
Simon's Observatory which I lead with my
friends at Berkeley and Princeton and
UPenn and Chicago so anyway Mark I want
to thank you for that but bring us back
to that to that time did you realize the
implications when you guys were working
on this paper were you mainly trying to
motivate why it would be interesting or
how one could study it or did you really
want to parse the differences between a
large expensive telescope and a small
you know relatively inexpensive
telescope
um I think that what happened there
if I remember is that um
there was sort of this mindset at the
time
um you know
the
you know the big CMB experiments at that
time the most successful one was Kobe
and you know we all knew Kobe we
understood how it worked we looked kind
of understood the analysis were and um
you know I was a grad sorry a postdoc in
the mid 90s early 90s and I started
getting interested in the CMB and I saw
you know and starting to work on the CMV
I went through a whole bunch of
calculations I gave myself exercises I
could sort of understand what was going
on and
um you know Kobe worked by scanning the
entire sky
and we sort of had this mindset that a
cosmic microwave background experiment
to be successful had to scan the entire
Sky
um and it turns out that Kobe was the
best
um strategy that full Sky strategy was
the best strategy for the signal that
they were trying to detect which was the
temperature fluctuations
um
and if you look at the you know the
power Spectrum for a CNB temperature
fluctuations it Peaks at large angular
scales and the fluctuations get become
much smaller amplitude at small angular
scales and so I you know I wasn't around
when they designed Kobe but in
retrospect that was the best way to
actually discover what they wanted and
ultimately discovered
um but then you know in the mid 90s I
and Arthur and Albert Stevens and urush
and Matthias and other people were
writing papers about the polarization
and one of the things that was striking
about the polarization is that the
fluctuations in the polarization
um are larger on small angular scales
than on large angular scales and so we
did the straightforward calculation of
the paper that you're thinking about
which was essentially just a
generalization of like the kinds of
exercises that I and other people had
given ourselves you know to learn about
how these measurements are done but um
it was pretty clear just looking at the
polarization power spectrum that since
it Peaks at smaller angular scales you
don't need the full sky and you don't
need all it also not a piece on smaller
angles get sort of Peaks at middling
angular scales they also didn't need you
know the extremely high angular
resolution that we were pushing for in
our efforts to like you know uh advocate
for experiments like wmap to measure of
plasma to measure on cosmological
parameters
so it's a pretty straightforward
exercise the conclusions in that paper
probably could have been reached just by
looking at the polarization power
Spectrum without actually any detailed
calculation
um but I think putting in the intent of
putting in that paper was to like draw
attention to this
um because you know I'm not an observer
I was even less of an observer back then
but I did know enough to know that you
don't need a big telescope to do
um you don't need particularly good into
a resolution and I also know enough that
it's easier to appoint a telescope or
small part of the sky than the entire
Scott
I think we took the title of that paper
from
a book that had been written called the
Higgs Hunters Guide yes
um
for
um article theorists onion Haver Sally
Dawson
and I'm gonna get in trouble okay
yeah I think it was Gordy yeah yeah I
have the best one of those books that
you buy and you never read uh but
because I I thought I thought it was
slightly more practical to build
something to look for gravitational
waves you know on a table top size then
look for the Higgs uh but we'll get to
the Higgs and we'll get to other other
challenges and crises and cosmology but
just a quick pause to ask you for a
small favor while my thumb is occupied
with old Albert on it yours is
presumably freed up to leave a thumbs up
on this video really helps me a lot with
it good old-fashioned YouTube algorithm
thanks a lot now back to the video but
but I guess the question I had is you
know back then you were also responsible
for the formalism which I think is both
more you know poetic uh I fight with
Matthias about this all the time uh you
know EB versus grad curl I think it's
more evocative more descriptive to use
the description you and Arthur and uh
Stevens came up with but but the kind of
milieu if I remember from middle of my
graduate school in the mid 90s late 90s
that was also concomitant with looking
for you know Cosmic sheer or looking for
Galaxy sheer and correlations which I
want to ask you about that because I
don't really hear so much about I mean
we hear about gravitational lensing and
even in the CMB but these were in like
kind of optical surveys if I recall
correctly where you first really and
maybe it was Stebbins you know who had
with Nick Kaiser if I recall correctly
and others that really started to look
into these you know Brad curl type
phenomena but in contradistinction to
the CMB I almost never hear about those
types of measurements what what happened
there did we just solve that field or
did it get superseded in some way
you mean
um replenishing of galaxies yeah just
Optical you know surveys of weak lensing
and in the formalism of grad curl you
know and presenting it
people do that it's huge it's um it's
one of the cornerstones of you know the
DS Dark Energy survey analyzes
cosmological analyzes that Galaxy
clustering they've got bearing acoustic
oscillations but they also have weak
cleansing so that's huge
um
formalism or are they like how what is
the kind of metric rubric that they're
using because I remember back oh geez
you know ground and curl
so they're looking for they're using
weak lensing to measure the mass
distribution and for them it's just the
grad or the e-mode
um they don't really need the curl
there's no reason they don't really need
the curl for anything
um or the P mode
um you can use it um you can measure it
with a experiment I think they do
um is a null test all right so very good
null test because it's the you know the
whole analysis pipeline that you that
you developed uh to measure the emote
um you can just change essentially one
line of the code just rotate everything
by 45 degrees and then do the same
measurement that gives you the B mode or
the curl component and um you're doing
everything right that should be zero
right so it's a it's an unfortunately
yeah so they do they use it but they
don't use the language of E versus B
because it's not really uh they just
have cleansing
now that's tracing matter distribution I
mean it what what to what does that owe
itself to is it is it too dark matter at
low z because obviously you know Plank
and other CNB act and spt and so forth
and polar bear can measure you know
gravitational lensing at high red shift
and Trace things along the line of sight
and there's a redshift kernel that is
involved but what is the if you had a
rank kind of the DS and other surveys
you know kind of motive force or
motivation for them I mean what to what
extent does weak lensing you know hold a
candle no pun intended to things like
Baron acoustic oscillations and other
other phenomenals it's right up there I
mean it's not better or worse it's
different
um if you look uh there's been a lot of
attention to this Sigma 8 tension in
recent years
and you can look um you know they're you
can look at the papers or you can look
at the summary plots that people show in
conferences there's a whole bunch of
different data points measurements of
this amplitude of clustering and the
current uniforms or recent universe and
some of those come from weak lensing
some of them come from Galaxy clustering
um and they're all falling more or less
in this a little bit low compared to
what you expect from the CMB and they
all have comparable error bars
so yeah weak lensing of galaxies is I
think right in there it's one of the the
Cornerstone you know physical cosmology
measurements that people are doing that
so we've got a lot of guests on recently
talking about alternatives to things
like inflation to things like lorentz
invariance as a as a you know conserved
symmetry we'll get to those but the one
I want to turn to First in our list of
crises which goes along you know hand in
glove perhaps with uh you know weak
lensing that we just discussed uh are
alternatives to particulate dark matter
um and those are things like Monde uh so
I've had on Stacy McGaw from my alma
mater undergrad alma mater Case Western
and also from Mordecai Milgram uh from
uh from from Israel so I had both of
them on discuss their their and it seems
to me and maybe I'm wrong but there's
almost
um it seems to be like a Renaissance now
with with people looking at Mond but of
course you know you you're not bound by
any you know uh desire to play politics
it'll tell me what you really think how
seriously should I take Mom I'm just a
simple humble experimental cosmologist
Mark so break it down for me and my
audience
what do you as a National Academy you
know the one of the most respected
cosmologists alive uh what do you think
of of mod on a practical basis has it
cleared any hurdles that would cause you
to say put your money or the nsf's money
where their Mounds are and put a grad
student or a postdoc sick them on a
problem
um honestly I don't like bonds I don't
some whether I like it or not I don't
pay attention to it and I'm gonna say
something that I often say and you know
in small groups
don't worry there's only three thousand
people subscribed don't worry I just I
don't think it's
good science
um so Stacy does these analyzes that I
think are interesting
um you know Stacy's got a whole bunch of
galaxies for which it has well measured
rotation curves and then he fits you
know semi-analytic curves to those data
and I think that um that's interesting
and I think um a it's a it's a useful
piece of information or a set of a data
set that
um theories for Galaxy formation and
Galaxy structure should in principle be
able to account for
um
I don't however like the idea of Mond as
an alternative to
dark matter
and the reason is it's just not the
theoretical business
um we've been developing you know our
modern
model for physics
um for a long long time started you know
quantitative descriptions of nature
started with Isaac Newton they were
developed further by assorted
mathematicians and physicists in several
centuries
um you know Einstein then took things
further in terms of a relativistic
description and it didn't so you know it
didn't rule out or replace Newtonian
gravity but expanded the realm of
applicability and clarified the realm of
applicability and then you know the big
mom was we found quantum mechanics we
found that there's you know certain
mathematical framework that describes
the behavior fundamental particles
um
now the mathematics that underlies all
these things is complicated but it's
always motivated by the most simple
physical principles and the most simple
ideas that we have in nature the most
Elementary things that you can think of
are firmly encoded in those mathematical
theories so you know one thing that we
start with when we develop a
mathematical model for physics you know
the workings of the universe is we say
it should be Universal we shouldn't have
one theory that works on Earth
another one that works on Mars one that
works on Tuesday and one that works on
Thursdays
um we should have one physical Theory
that explains phenomena everywhere and
at all times
and so that notion of the invariance of
the laws of physics under time
translation and spatial translations
gives rise to conservational momentum
and energy
we can then generalize those to the
relativistic context that Einstein
brought us to and again that gives us
additional symmetries of the laws of
physics further constraints on the
mathematical structure and in quantum
mechanics we have internal we have
rotational symmetry spatial translation
symmetries you know all these very
simple common sense
very basic Common Sense the laws of
physics shouldn't depend on whether I
look in that direction or that direction
that gives us conservation of angular
momentum and Mom just doesn't have these
symmetries built into it
um the mathematical structure is sort of
will try what works here
and over here we'll try something else
and um
it's just uh I don't like it so it's
it's it's not only philosophic it's not
only sort of uh you know based on on
philosophy but you know as they say the
the Gustavus
sesputandam you know you can't really
account for Taste but just to push back
with my trademark love and respect for
you
um aren't the most interesting things in
physics the result of broken symmetries
not not perfectly I mean if symmetry was
absolute
that's a very good point but
um
the broken symmetries that we have in
nature
um are manifestations of situations the
the the underlying symmetry is still
built into the mathematics so for
example the election week standard model
um the theory has built into it certain
internal symmetries we refer to as Su 3
cross se2 across if you want the su2
cross U1 symmetry the electric standard
model is spontaneously broken
um so when we discuss the low energy you
know observational
um phenomenological consequences of the
theory they are in this broken symmetry
phase
but the underlying symmetry still
um
is apparent in the mathematical
structure
I mean another example is when we look
at um you know condensed matter physics
so and you know according to what I said
the laws of physics should be invariant
under translation but when you look at a
crystal you know and that's a matter of
physics you've got a regular periodic
array of atoms and so you no longer have
um you know spatial translation symmetry
um unless it's by that certain lattice
separation
um but still the the
underlying physical theory is still
invariant under spatial translations but
subject to the you know but describe the
particular physical configurations
you're looking at
so even when we have spontaneously
broken symmetries
um in nature of the underlying symmetry
is still built into the it's still
respected I see so what about I was
speaking on a podcast with my colleague
Dan Green uh who uh is you know renowned
and astroparticle physics and
um kind of making a slow conversion from
you know String Theory as a you know
daily practice or you know the daily
homage to string theory and I'm really
getting into observational signatures
for for experiments like the Simon's
Observatory but
um you know I asked him yesterday I'll
ask you later you know what are some of
the most you know foundational things
that you've learned or facts about the
universe that you'd want to brag about
and put on a monument a time capsule to
last a billion years we'll get to that
for you later but he was basically
saying like effective field Theory you
know is is extremely is extremely uh
productive and and it's it's led to
multiple discoveries high energy physics
and and so forth but um but it made me
think you know of this of this fact that
we we hear things from people like Nema
uh up the road from you at Princeton and
others that you know space time is
doomed and and uh there's really nothing
you know I think I think yeah I can't
really repeat what he said but uh
because it's a PG no he he hopefully
will come on the podcast but but you
know essentially that you know it's it's
it's it's it's only we're only seeing
kind of a a shadow of of some low energy
limit of some higher energy effective
field so admission made me think what is
so crazy about thinking about Newtonian
Dynamics I mean why is that so
sacrosanct
um the symmetries in it we knew since
the time of of Isaac Newton
we both have great affinity for
um but that we knew since you know that
there were there were flaws in it and
inherently contradictions that needed to
be revealed and and corrected by a true
but still effective Theory like gr and
so why hold sucker saying you know these
these prints or the Newtonian physics
you know all the more so uh you know if
we aren't really sure that we have a
final true theory only an effective
Theory what do you say to you know kind
of those
I have I agree with Dan that effective
theories have been very very successful
but the reason they've been successful
is the the idea of effective field
theories is to identify the symmetries
of the system and then construct a class
of mathematical models a general class
of mathematical models that are
consistent with those symmetries
and but Amanda does not do that it
doesn't it's not in some sense it's not
mathematically self-consistent you know
I don't want to
I probably can't get through all the
details both mind if you sort of start
with over here and then you go over here
and then you go over here and then you
go over here and then you go right here
game of telephone you know yeah you know
tomorrow is this is Super Bowl Sunday
and then by the time it comes back it's
like you know you know Franklin Delaware
Roosevelt is about to be Resurrected
it doesn't hang together
yeah there are issues with you know kind
of I think superpositions and linearity
and so forth but let's take the opposite
attack now let me get your impressions
about a highly symmetric Theory and and
uh some would say a super symmetric
theory in other words you know particle
physics we you know we've been kind of
living under this notion that there's
some unification that's possible
um and that you know there's a theory of
everything that lurking uh perhaps um
for models that that basically ape or
replicate you know very simple
symmetries from things like relativist
decline Gordon equations and and make
those you know operate on manifolds with
vibrating string I mean that's very
symmetric right and and are those past
guests you know Sabina hasenfelder Neil
Turok and others who argue that we've
been LED astray by Beauty and the
Symmetry and that it's no longer you
know in last 50 years pursuing that was
very fruitful for the preceding 30 years
but you know until the time of your you
know fellow Professor gel on Caltech you
know I don't I don't see that it's been
as productive as to Warrant you know the
attention to it versus the attention the
you know you know pitiful amount of
attention to something like mon which I
agree is doesn't have those symmetry so
how do you reconcile those two sides you
know where you're advocative of pursuing
things that have inherent properties
Beauty symmetry Etc and yet in string
theory and supersymmetry they haven't
borne any fruit at least not yet
I think the issue is that um you know
ultimately what we do as physicists
um a scientist his construct
mathematical models to explain results
of experiments and observation
and the simpler the mathematical model
the better
um and but you want that mathematical
model to be mathematically
self-consistent and you also want to
satisfy certain basic requirements
and the basic requirements you know are
consistent with the the symmetries that
are either assumed or observed
experimentally
um and throughout the 20th century we
were lucky because
um you know
for various historical
societal reasons and just you know
technological advances and capabilities
we were able to very rapidly uncover you
know a variety of layers
you know first going down to the atom
and then into the constituency atom the
nucleus the electron protons and
neutrons the quarks left you know Etc
um and we were we had a lot of
experimental data that guided us and
told us what the symmetries were you
look at the data and they're the
patterns we had tons of information you
know when boar came across you know came
up with the you know his model for the
the hydrogen atom
um chemists and physicists have been
measuring spectral lines from various
types of gases for 50 years like huge
huge tables of all these numbers and all
of a sudden you know with the Bohr's
model he started you start to have some
insight on where those numbers came from
you know bomber I think it was the 1860s
or something like that when he came up
with this formula that was the one paper
that he wrote but still it took him 50
years from that to you know a model but
then after that things you know what's
wrong I mean the Bohr Adam is not the
true description of the atom but it's
remarkably effective at a plane it was a
phenomenal it was a a simple
mathematical model to account for the
the you know some of the observations
and then it led the way
um you know with more data more insights
more measurements to you know more
fundamental what we believe now is a
more fundamental description but we got
lucky in the 20th century we had Nuclear
Physics we had protons and neutrons we
had beta Decay we had all these
different nuclear impatient decaying and
then hadron spectroscopy you had
neutrons and protons and Pines and chaos
and romezons
it was just like all over the place and
then you know we had accelerators and we
had the w we had the Z we had Precision
tests of um you know qcd
um you know we had uh what's it called
Reggie
trajectories is that what's called um we
had um we had um you know the part-time
model deep in elastics pattern so it's
just a huge amount of information
um and so our mathematical models were
guided
you know we like to think that we're you
know everything was because of you know
some type of like genius Insight
um The Genius insights were pretty
Elementary it's got to be mathematically
self-consistent It's gotta account for
the observation experiments we had so
much data and you know guiding us but
you know now we've kind of you know
I don't know if we haven't hit a wall
but we're getting slower the you know
the
the sizes and price tags for
accelerators are going to take us to the
next level keeps getting you know bigger
the time scales price tags are bigger
time scales are longer and so we just
don't have the same kind of guidance
from an experiment that we did
you know 50 hundred years ago I don't
think that you know that should lead us
to abandon the notion of symmetry it's
just that we just don't know what the
what those symmetries are and so it's
you know been happening over the past 30
40 50 years is largely
guesswork
we try guessing some symmetries maybe
there's a left right symmetric model
maybe they're super symmetric models
maybe there's you know generalized
symmetries
But ultimately we're limited because we
don't have data
so now of course the the ultimate of all
symmetries at least in cosmology is the
cosmological principle and and lately
you know the first kind of Crisis we're
going to talk about
um is the notion of claim at pretty high
significance by by many other by many
people but in particular subie or SAR
Khan
group that Oxford I think where he's at
but other ones that that claim that the
cosmological principle should be not
overthrown but needs to be evaluated in
the context of the distribution of radio
galaxies versus the CMB dipole versus
um other tracers ksz things like that
what what do you make of I mean first of
all what what you know would you just
quit and and go back to you know
slinging pizzas and uptown Manhattan or
what would you do if the cosmological
principle it needs uh needs to be
jettisoned I mean we just go into like
apoplexy or or what and then second of
all what sort of mental energy do you
expend on such claims
um I actually think it's these kinds of
tests are very important and very
interesting
um I think if we found a violation of
the cosmological principle I wouldn't
think of that as the end of the world or
the end of the universe
um in some sense
um
we might even expect it at some level
um one thing I tell my students is that
in in physics there's no such thing as
an integer there's no such thing as an
irrational number there's no such thing
as zero there's no such thing as
Infinity
you know ultimately all of our models
are approximations to the reality to
reality and again the cosmological
principle
um is great as a you know when it comes
to assembling our model of what it knows
essential tool in guiding the
development of our current cosmological
model
but
um you know our notion of inflation is
that the universe is not perfectly
homogeneous there are variations from
one point to another and we know that
we've got galaxies we've got primordial
perturbation Cosmic microwave background
and there's no reason to expect that on
super Horizon distances which we can't
access observationally that there might
be departures from you know perfect
homogeneity nisotropy and so if we did
find the cosmological principles
violated if we did find those a
preferred orientation in the universe
um
I think that'll be great
it'll be great you know because we where
there's a limit to what we can infer
from whatever observations we have and
there might be subtle departures from
the things we've always assumed that are
going to lead us in that direction
of these kinds of
tests I always think I think we should
always be testing you know all of the
assumptions that we've made we shouldn't
hold anything you know sacred or holy
let's say you know God hands you you
know a letter and it says a cosmological
principle is not valid you know on this
scale at you know at five Sigma seven
Sigma whatever
um correct me if I'm wrong I mean that
really wouldn't affect I mean we
wouldn't like change the you know the B
mode power Spectra you know for example
it wouldn't it wouldn't undo in the
relevant you know cosmological epochs
surface of last scattering even Bao even
Epoch of of you know Lambda domination
would it really haven't like would you
have to change you know uh cam or CMB
fast as we used to use it um whether it
be any practical implication on a daily
basis other than like cosmologists don't
know what they're talking about uh you
know what would it how would it affect
your life or my life as working
cosmologists if at all
um I think if there was if we did find
there was a preferred orientation
preferred Direction in the universe
um ultimately it would affect
um
you know the calculation of cosmological
observables
um we do know that any departure of
strong homogeneity or isotropy are very
very small
and so it wouldn't be like a huge you
would have to throw cam away completely
but there might I mean hopefully if
we're doing things you know for making
progress sooner or later there would be
some type of tweak of cam or plastic
we'd have to implement
um
yeah yeah but I mean suppose somebody
came in and they said you know
the Earth
you know Columbus Christopher Columbus
comes in your office one day
okay in the 1400s he says the Earth is
round you're like
and then he like sails around he says
okay watch I'm going that way he leaves
and then you know six later years later
he comes back from that side yes it is
wrong you demonstrate I believe it it's
round and then you go down the hallway
to you know your theoretical physics
group you say look
Christopher Columbus has found that the
Earth is round he went that way and he
came back this way and then for the next
50 years people decide the Earth is
round and that is we have the Earth is
round principle which is a fundamental
principle of you know of Earth studies
and then somebody winds up taking a trip
to the Himalayas and they see that the
Himalayas are really big and they come
back and say the Earth isn't round
the Earth is not round it's got bumps in
it yes yes but it's still round it's not
perfectly round but it's pretty damn
close that's right and it's like those
bumps are interesting they're
interesting they tell us a lot about the
history of the earth and its Evolution
and its structure but it does not
eliminate the Earth is rounds principle
I think that's where we are with the
cosmology we have this cosmological
principle the universe should be
homogeneous and isotropic but we know
that it's not perfectly homogeneous it's
not perfectly isotropic we've supplanted
that now with the notion of statistical
homogeneity and statistical isotropy and
those
um are very very good descriptions of
the universe but there's no reason
expecting them to be perfect and if we
find violations that'll be great because
any such violation is not going to
overturn the entire structure of
cosmological theory but it'll tell us
it'll give us a you know a lot more
clues about where the universe came from
yeah as a another shout out to a famous
Isaac and we already talked about Isaac
Newton Isaac Asimov said you know if you
believe the Earth is flat you're wrong
and if you believe the Earth is a sphere
you're also wrong but you're less wrong
and uh that's a guiding principle I
think for what yeah good science uh
should be and I want to Pivot from from
that to the you know to maybe moving
forward in time from you know the Big
Bang itself uh which will get back to
maybe talk about inflation later on but
um but there was a kind of a social
contagion that went on over the summer
uh where uh there's a lot of attention
paid to an article written by uh a
person who went to Colombia he might
have even been there when you were there
uh named Eric Lerner who's a plasma uh
physicist he's interested in Fusion all
sorts of fun things not a PhD not a
professor but he has this you know book
from the 90s called The Big Bang never
had and and this article went around
based on the web telescope data of early
spiral galaxy observations
that the you know he claims there's not
enough time since the Big Bang to
generate uh this spiral phenomena and
that it's in conflict with other things
and so he believes in a steady state a
static universe uh which has Myriad
problems and and I debated him not I
kind of had an asynchronous debate with
him uh and uh had Garen Lewis on and he
and I spoke about about this this
gentleman's work but anyway
uh what do you make of this if let's say
we were to really and as I think it is
true that we don't understand why these
galaxies observed by Hubble first in the
90s when he wrote the book the first
time or web galaxies which are higher
redshift and redder and easier to see
with web than HST but still some of them
were seen by uh Hubble
um why why is it that you know people
you know what would that call into
question or if anything does it does it
cause us to reevaluate Lambda CDM uh
does it cause us to reevaluate only and
I say only in quotes you know Galaxy
structure formation what what do you
mean did you hear about these claims
what do you make of them if if you're
hearing about them for the first time I
didn't hear about these claims but
claims like this
come around all the time
yeah I mean I remember
when I was in graduate school
postdoc people were starting to discover
galaxies of redshift close to one
ruled out the cosmological model because
how can you make a Galaxy All the Way by
Rich matters or this cluster of galaxies
and redshift of one and then like Quasar
start appearing you know at higher Rich
if how can you make the quasars there's
just not enough time for it there's also
this issue people there were ages for
stars people had um Stellar ages or
elaborate stars and collaborate clusters
that were older you know than the age of
the universe
how's that happen that's kind of rules
rules out there but I remember you
probably didn't know David Schram David
Schram was a larger than life figure
yeah
yeah and uh I remember it was one of
these debates going on at the time and
you know it came into class
and he said you know
the Earth is round we'd understand how
tornadoes form it's very complicated but
we do not have a successful theory of
tornadoes that consistent with around
Earth but that does not mean that the
Earth isn't round it means we'd
understand how tornadoes form it's the
same thing going on here
um galaxies especially these five
reduction galaxies are very complicated
is a lot more complicated but they're
not as well observed
measured uh you know
as local galaxies but they're very
complicated objects
um that's just a University of Illinois
UIUC last week I was talking to the
storage Shapiro and I was asking him
um if what if he knows how supermassive
black holes perform
so BC Quasar is a very high red shift
with very large masses you know quasers
get a 10 billion solar masses an adult
and it's not clear how you get so much
mass in such a small
volume how you produce such a massive
black hole a such a short period of time
but the ideas about this how this might
happen
and it doesn't violate any fundamental
physical
you know theorem
uh I don't know how these supermassive
black holes are formed to me that's the
most interesting puzzle but it doesn't
I've never worried that it invalidates
the
our cosmological models no more so than
our inability to predict weather
patterns invalidates are
the Earth is round principle
so um I wanted uh to now pivot into more
maybe I always say red meat but I'm
going to say
um you know vegan white tofu uh for My
Vegan listeners
um and that's something near and dear to
to both of our hearts and that's the the
so-called Hubble tension which is one of
the more prominent tensions at least in
observational cosmology and I had on
Adam Reese your colleague there I had on
John Mather also calling there uh and
you know we discussed some of these some
of these issues uh but I'm tired of the
blandishments Marco I'm trying to well
we need more data I want somebody to
come out tell me what the heck's going
on and and not postpone or say you know
if we don't understand it that would be
really exciting it's like remember when
like in the 90s when they said we're
going to build LHC
and or the late you know late 90s
relationship we're going to build the
LHC and if we don't find the Higgs
that'll be really exciting like if you
don't find the Higgs you're all going to
be out of a job you know so
let's let's talk you know brass tax here
what's going on and who's right what
this I I know you're a man of very
strong opinions and you won't weasel or
waffle out of this who's right Mark tell
tell me I need to know
really honestly I have no idea what's
going on if you had a bet if you had a
bet your your new dog your Rottweiler I
don't know
um first of all can you outline from
your perspective you know why this is
important first outline that you know
upper level undergraduate sort of level
uh for my brilliant audience but what is
a Hubble tension is it a problem
um you know we have Exquisite
measurements from two different camps
they don't agree but what are the
implications for cosmology
I don't know I mean I get asked this all
the time you know what's going on
talk straight to me I can handle it DOC
I don't know I mean if I actually knew
that there was something wrong with the
CMV analysis they were just you know
they forgot to like you know
you know
there's C code they just forgot to like
put the right compiler flag on it or
something or if they just missed a
factor of two somewhere if I knew that I
would have
I would have published it I would have
told the world and we wouldn't be
worrying about it same thing with the
Supernova date if I like went in there
and realized oh you're just pointing the
telescope at the wrong exception
variable you know that's the one you're
supposed to be looking at then we
wouldn't be worrying about it I mean I
really don't no
um I mean CMB analyzes I know and
understand
um
and there's nothing wrong with them a
lot of people have looked at them we've
got data from several different
telescopes
um
that data's been analyzed and
re-analyzed by a variety of different
people and groups and you know the
Hubble parameter that we infer from all
those measurements is low 67 and 68.
and then they're the Supernova measure
and um I'm kind of in a
probably have a different opinion or
view of this than most other people
um because when I go to work I walk past
Adam's office in the morning
and I see him and he's always in front
of his screen actually calculated and
damn it okay he's not like uh just
smoking cigars and like having the
people
he's actually like
and you know every couple of days or
every couple weeks on archive there's
some paper that appears or someone says
well they forgot to take into account
the metallicity evolution or they forgot
to take a look out and then they go past
Adam's office I'm like hey did you see
this paper on archive about the metal
issue it'll say well actually yeah you
know what they said is correct you're
taking the continentalistic evolution
but look he did it and then he'll show
me you know I'll go to the screen third
results he said okay this is the
analysis you know without it and this is
the analysis with it and they're right
it does move things down but it's half a
sigma and it's already in the analysis
we already take that into account and so
you know all these like you know things
that people you know
you know lob at the measurements he he
bats them all the way and so
and he also does the now like he does
the CMB analysis it's you know I
couldn't do the Supernova now he's a
very impressive scientist yeah and it's
not just that the other thing um so I
told you I wrote this in rev article on
public attention to the dark energy
without him and I'm familiar with the
observations that people have done but
in the process of writing the article
and actually like you know Adam wrote
most of the observational Parts but you
know I want to read through and make
sure everything hangs together and uh
you know and understand and also
um at the same time
um I'm across the street from the Space
Telescope Science Institute and so I see
Space Telescope you know scientists
there and one of the things I've come to
appreciate is that um you know there's a
huge amount of
um calibration and um benchmarking and
bootstrap tests and Engineering
infrastructure behind HST
and it's the same telescope that's been
making all the measurements that they
use for these for these Hubble parameter
measurements you know over the past 30
years
and um and so it's not like they're you
know using one telescope to observe this
system another telescope to observe that
system and then try to figure out how to
calibrate this one against that there's
a lot of you know it's it's all
calibrated against itself internally
calibrated and so it's not that you know
someone's just being
sloppy or forgetting to do something
this is as careful of measurement I
think you know
as any that you would find anything yeah
and so it's not something that's just
easily waved away and so when people ask
me you know what's going on you know
who's wrong I just I don't know
I spoke here remotely at least two
months ago at UCSD in Berkeley we have
this kind of joint oh yeah energy astral
product and you spoke about possible
solutions to it and and I
um I brought up my favorite personal
favorite and I I beg your Indulgence
just to hear the reason why of course
you're very familiar with primordial
magnetic fields but uh that's my
preferred explanation for it uh you know
based on work by Levon pagosian and
another colleague of his um uh whose
name I'm forgetting right now but I did
a video about how their paper basically
you know could lead to a possible
solution of the reconciliation of the
tension without costly Psychotherapy and
the argument you know could be better
recapitulated by you but nevertheless uh
the reason I like it are philosophically
attracted to it is that we know magnetic
fields exist and we don't know exactly
how magnetic fields the size of a micro
guy house come to be in the Milky Way
galaxy or you know Nana you know Nano
Gauss and the inter-cluster medium but
we've never detected correct me if I'm
wrong a truly primordial magnetic field
uh and yet we see the the the you know
kind of the the Sprouts that must have
emerge from some primordial seed so what
do you make of the solution via the
primordial field since there's you know
an infinite number of possible you know
resolutions theoretical explanations for
the Hubble tension what do you make of
that argument that the primordial
magnetic field energy plays a role and
then what do you make of your own uh
model or uh suggestion uh that it might
be due to evolution of some primordial
field or so forth but you'll be better
equipped to deal with explanations as
well so first what are your you know
kind of straw man and Steel Man the
primordial magnetic field and then the
models that you've worked on
um I like the primordial magnetic field
idea because as you say it's economical
um we don't have to completely reinvent
fundamental physics
come up with these scalar Fields with
wacky potentials that we had no idea why
they would be there
um the
um only
it's not an issue I think
um
the limitation with the magnetic fields
so the only reason I don't just jump up
and say I think it's going to be a
magnetic field is that um it's very
difficult to calculate fully the
implications of these primordial
magnetic fields
um it's fundamentally non-linear you
know the standard cosmological model
when we describe customer pick
background and massage because we got
lucky
um it's a simple system the fluctuation
amplitudes are small and so we know how
to calculate
um you know our priori it didn't have to
be that way if the primordial density
perturbation amplitude was more like 10
to the minus two instead of 10 to the
minus five which is as likely from a
theoretical point of view is 10 to the
minus five
um then we would have had a much harder
time actually you know interpreting
the data
and primordial magnetic fields it's the
the theory is fundamentally non-linear
and so it's just difficult to calculate
um
but you know
see
yeah I think it probably warrants more
attention and more effort
um that's just not something that I have
yet done I think it is interesting and
important and so much to do it maybe I
should do it but I just haven't yet okay
and I'll talk about the model you
discussed
um our seminar yeah
I mean early Dark Energy you know the
the minus is that we introduced this
with into this scalar field with
features and parameters that come out of
nowhere
um the advantage that we know how to
calculate the same type of perturbation
Theory
and so we can you know write down the
mathematical model
and then evolve it
calculate and you know figure out the
the observational implications and it
works
I don't know why it works I don't
I can't say look there's a it's just
what the doctor ordered and you know
this is you know there's this is exactly
what we would have expected it's kind of
a back to maybe model
um
and from the point of view of you know
what you know your particle theory
friends would call a UV completion
um
I mean we don't know where this comes
from but it does work
um and I have to say when we wrote that
paper in 2018 I did not expect it to
work I thought we would write you know
an upper limits paper you know we tried
to do this and in this paper we showed
that this ridiculous idea in fact as you
might have expected doesn't work
to move on with your lives
um but you know it turns out that it did
work it was surprising and I found that
you know interesting that it could work
because none of the other Solutions work
all the late time solutions they don't
work so to me this was a model
a ridiculous model but at least it works
once you're willing to take this bitter
pill everything else follows
um and other people get interested in
WoW as well and um I think until we have
anything better right so you know
somebody comes in and you know you know
shows that the you know lines 683 in the
C code that they've been using to
analyze the the ACT data you know I was
missing a comma that changes everything
um
but I don't proselytize I don't think
it's the truth so I don't have to be
more interesting and then we got lucky I
don't really understand it then you know
act came out with an analysis two years
later
and you know the lead author is Colin
Hill and Colin is like really knows what
he's doing with data
and it's unbiased you know he had
written several earlier papers analyzing
large-scale structure showing that it
was disfavored early dark energy
and then he was the first author on this
act collaboration paper
where they looked at the data fully
objectively without any intended
consequence without any biases and they
found that the ACT data was um more
consistent with early Dark Energy within
Lambda CDN which I don't I mean a lot of
uncertainties and issues you know that
in some ways it's something that's a
very preliminary analysis I don't think
it's at all the last word it was done on
the fraction of the ACT data it was done
fairly early on and as you know whenever
you do a CMD experiment you don't just
get straight to the science results you
discover the science simultaneously with
the instrument
very valued collaborator on Simon's
Observatory and and of course he'll be
uh having a lot more to say when our
instrument gets first light next year uh
over there in the Atacama Desert
pivoting back to where we began with
broken symmetries uh I mentioned you
know if not for the broken symmetry
between matter and antimatter yeah you
and I wouldn't be having this
conversation and yet it's a very tiny
asymmetry but it's you know hard to
think of something more impactful and I
was reading a paper which you know I I
remember when it came out because I
remember the events by the alpha
magnetic spectrometer on the space
station back uh five six years ago and
then remember the paper that came out
that Vivian uh pulan wrote with with you
and and several others including Joe
silk uh and that was entitled uh you
know where do these uh anti-thelium
events come from so uh we won't talk so
much about the uh results although I'm
not sure that they did stand up to you
know further reanalysis or were they
confirmed uh can you first say something
about that and then can you talk about
these anti-helium and anti-matter clouds
uh that are existent in this model uh
and how they could provide the source of
some of these uh of these particles that
seem to be observed at least by the AMS
on the ISS so first of all are these
measurements still you know uh are they
still credible or or do we have further
you know disconfirmation about that you
didn't warn me that you're going to ask
me about this
yeah yeah I remember I know the paper I
remember the paper I haven't kept up
though with it that's the thing
um so when we wrote that paper the the
anti-healing results were not yet
refereed
um or sort of talks and it was
understood that it was preliminary
um but even though it's preliminary
there are certain interesting things
about it that um were unusual and caught
our eye
so I don't really know what the status
of that is I have not heard a lot more
um the anti-clouds were kind of a crazy
idea
um and I don't think that
you know when I looked at that paper in
that model
I didn't necessarily
put it forward as a model of what I
think is actually going on but um sort
of as a model of how crazy things would
have to get
if this result holds up ah right so I
mean how how much do we because this I
want to Pivot to the extremely early
universe
saccharov conditions and whatnot so
um how do you you know kind of get your
attention drawn to an anomaly or a
crisis
um you know in in cosmology versus
particle physics and you know how much
progress could we make
um the you know baryon antivirion
asymmetry problem from Pure cosmological
you know insights observations data uh
pure Theory you know how much of a
concern is it that you know I mean the
critic will say well you have this
edifice built on Sand you've got all
this you know uh or anti-sand you've got
all these dark Forces and Fields you you
know 95 of the universe is completely
alien to us if they exist at all some
people say like Milgram it doesn't exist
um and even people say that dark energy
doesn't exist I think sarkar had some
papers about this uh these you know
prominent people so uh what do you say
to people that like how can you predict
you know that we'll see fluctuations in
the CMB from inflationary you know
gravitational waves if you don't even
know why there's matter versus
antimatter in the universe uh to what
extent do that type of tension keep you
up at night I think there are two things
that I think
that interests me
so one of them is that in cosmology and
particle physics
there are tons of anomaly
just tons at any given day there's like
tons of measurements that disagree with
what we would have expected based on the
standard model or our modeling of
astrophysical systems
and then there are tons of theorists
thinking about things but for some
reason
um
the vast majority of theorists tend to
gravitate or cluster around a very
narrow range of anomalies
and
um I think to a large extent
cosmologists are bosons and if
somebody's thinking about the Hubble
tension they will also think about the
Hubble tension they're not going to
think okay
there's 16 people thinking about the
humble tension that's good that's a very
important tension we don't understand it
so much to be thinking about it but then
over here there's this other tension and
maybe we should have you know eight or
nine or ten people thinking about that
and then you know there should be you
know if this was a business
you know we would have a manager at the
top and says okay there's this tension
there's this tension there's this
tension okay you choose five people to
be on your team you think about this
tension saldaryaga we got this tension
over here take five of your friends go
think about that kazowski we need you
guys in Pittsburgh to be looking about
this tension but it doesn't work that
way everybody decides what they're gonna
do and everybody winds up focusing in a
very narrow range of um problems
um that is the question you know what
when do I choose no how do I choose what
to work on
I don't really know but I think um
I think
you know
some approximation I have some students
and post docs and I have collaborators
elsewhere and we stood around and we
brainstorm we talk about things and we
read papers and uh
occasionally you know I mean often will
you know talk about some anomaly that
appear in the data we'll try to
understand it and try to figure out you
know is there any simple obvious
explanation you know in the analysis or
in the interpretation
and you know most of the time we'll
conclude yeah it's another we understand
what's going on
and that's it we don't have anything
else to say but sometimes
um we'll see something like that and we
actually have something to say
um so one example is just a there's a
paper that showed up almost a year ago
an archive by Mark Postman and Todd
Lauer and the New Horizons team
hmm right and
um it was a very you know the style of
the paper was very astronomical it
looked like you know an app J abstract
the language was very
um astronomical and so I I think it just
passed a lot of people by
but I know Mark Postman because he's a
Space Telescope Science Institute and I
see him all the time and so I've read
you know through it and as it turns out
they did this incredible measurement so
you know about New Horizons yeah that
Pluto yeah so I took a pictures of Pluto
and Karen and it was like incredible
absolutely amazing that something that
humans built got that close to Pluto and
took such detailed pictures of Pluto and
Caron
less than a lifetime after Pluto was
discovered yeah and less than the human
life two years after launch right yeah
yeah
um and then but it didn't have any
breaks in it right they just sent it out
there then you got sail past Pluto take
a bunch of pictures yeah but we can't
but then it kept sailing on and then a
couple years later took a picture that
asked that Kuiper Belt object peanut
shaped thing but it's still out there
and it's moving you know it's going for
it's like 70 a.u from the Sun
so it turns out that um nobody has ever
been able to measure the cosmic Optical
background so you look at the sky
and it's dark
nobody's actually ever been able to
measure how bright the sky actually is
in Optical we know in radio frequency
that's the cosmic microwave background
nobody's ever been able to measure the
cosmic Optical background because
there's so much scattered light from the
sun
so even HST and jwst they're they're
above the Earth's atmosphere but they're
still you know they can't do this
measurement because they're still in the
solar system all right and there's a lot
of scattered life from the Sun so this
you know New Horizons the camera was not
that sophisticated it wasn't the
greatest thing that camera that
anybody's ever built it's not a jwst
camera but it was out there
70 a year from the Sun where the scatter
light from the sun is reduced by fours
of magnitude and so mark Postman toddler
went to the New Horizons people like
just point it at nowhere you're doing
nothing else with that it's gonna be a
while until they find another camera
belt out of it just point it at nothing
and take a picture and see what happens
and so they did that and they mentioned
the cosmic Optical background they got
the first High signal to noise
measurement the cosmic Optical
background
and the interesting thing was that Mark
Postman and Todd Lauer
um you know Mark Postman was involved in
the original Hubble Deep Field
he knows more as much about Galaxy
populations
um at high red shift at low red shift as
anybody yeah and so they had an
expectation of what the cosmic Optical
background would be due to the
integrated light from all the unresolved
galaxies that we know to be out there
and it turns out that the cosmic Optical
background they measured was twice what
they expected from all the galaxies
non-galaxy populations in the universe
the very first time that comes from some
star that we know about somewhere
there's another Photon coming from God
knows where so the reason so we wound up
writing a paper and the reason we wrote
a paper is that an obvious you know
exotic physics explanation is
um decay of an Axion particle two
photons
and um
my group had been working on this um new
type of cosmological measurement called
Blind intensity mapping
and um JPL your your friends
um you know Jamie Bach yeah yeah Jamie's
got this project called spirox it's
going to be launching you know for the
next year or two and it's going to do
live intensity mapping and we realize
that if that Cosmic Optical background
access is in fact due to decay of an
exotic particle it's going to show up in
spirits
um you know the many thousands of signal
the spirits is just
it's like gonna be like a taking candy
from a baby for Spirit to you know
verify or disprove this hypothesis
so that's the only idea we had the idea
that it might be to the two photons to
give an accident that is not at all
profound that would be an embarrassing
paper to write but we wrote the paper
because we were able to we knew that
this idea would be tested it was a great
Target for spirits
yeah and as soon as the humble tension
goes I mean I've been I I heard about it
a lot because you know Adam's at um and
Chuck is right down there next yeah
but here you know think about hearing
about a lot and um in 2016 I wrote this
paper Tommy Carl who's a graduate
student the basic idea behind early Dark
Energy again it's not that profound or
it's pretty simple and obvious
so we did write a simple paper about
that in 2016 but it took two more years
to actually do the complete analysis
um the to figure out whether this idea
could be made or
would that then happen you know we we as
you know look for a Time dependent
um but not but spatially isotropic
Cosmic birefringence polarization
rotation of emotes or grad modes into
curl modes as I will always call them
and uh we look for a time to so far we
haven't seen that bicep hasn't seen them
uh and and so forth would this signal I
mean is there any con kind of neutral
constraint or concomitant you know um
limit that could be put on let's say you
accept these at face value from uh from
New Horizons
would that give any kind of hope for you
to write a paper called the the Axion
pursuers guide or something like that
I don't think we need to write that
paper
because um
axions have just become the the
preferred
um you know Workforce for theorists
thinking about exotic new physics and
dark matter and dark energy and really
dark energy
um
I don't think I'll be the person to
write that I've written some papers
that have actions in them but
I'm a bit player in the hole all right
all right well I had on uh you know not
too long ago
um it was David David Chalmers who's
I think well he's in New York I think
he's at NYU actually not Columbia but
but anyway or maybe he's like but the
point is he's Australian he's originally
from Australia I said you know you're
well known uh for all these you know the
hard problem of Consciousness you know
and you know when I have AC DC also from
Australia on the into the impossible
podcast I can't not ask them to play You
Shook Me All Night Long it's just it's
just it's not fair to them to their Uber
um someone ask you you know is that
really the the Pioneer and a lot of
these ways of thinking and the
detectability of inflation
um or its constraint you know what is
the status of inflation from Markham
mankowski's perspective 30 years you
know after we met or uh you know we you
really were were initiating a whole
field which would become my you know my
source of of where my bread gets
buttered
what what do you view as the status of
inflation is it is it stronger than ever
but what's that what what kind of grade
would you give to inflation at this
point and um what what kind of
perspectives do you have for prospects
for what we're going to do in the future
um I have to say that
I mean the basic status of inflation
um the basic idea I think is the same as
it was 30 40 years ago
um there have been a lot of um
theoretical developments that are
interesting
um a lot of them done by people like Dan
Green
um
but also Leonardo sanatoreaga
Daniel Bowman there's been this whole um
Jared Kaplan at Thea Fitzpatrick
um there was a you know starting about
15 years ago there were still papers on
effective field Theory descriptions of
inflation
which I think are important because they
put inflation model building on that
level of mathematical self-consistency
um symmetries built in that I think
isn't you know one of the things we're
supposed to be doing in theoretical
physics in terms of observation
experiment I have to say that inflation
is doing far better I think than I ever
would have expected
30 years ago so it's almost 30 years ago
that I started writing papers on CMD
tests of inflation
and you know I was a postdoc and an
assistant professor and I was just
trying to write papers that made me seem
clever so that I'd get a job in the
container
and
um
and I remember once you know we were I
was giving a talk about cosmological
parameter determination with the CMB
this was you know 1995.
and it was before wmf was selected but
they were proposing it was a map at that
time and I remember talking to David
Wilkinson who was the W from it
and he said you shouldn't be soaked and
I was you know we wrote these papers
we're thinking in the best case
in the best case if they get all the
money in the world they have genius
instrument Builders and the thing
doesn't blow up on the launch pad and it
makes it you know they get the funding
and they make a little bit in the best
Pace they should be able to make this
measurement I remember David Wilkins who
came up to me after we're sick it's
really not that difficult he's like you
know it's not uh we can do this
and I was like really because you know
Kobe we were coming off of Kobe and you
know Kobe took more than 20 years from
conception to launch it's all steady
scenario yeah we have an experiment like
the the one the what we had in mind is
actually less than what map turned out
to be after a few years of observation
and I had in my mind this would take
another 20 years
you know before this happened but as it
turned out you know the first results
the first you know results on um the the
you know the first acoustic peaks in the
CNB power Spectrum came from Boomerang
in Spring of 2000 and then a year later
there was you know further measurements
from Daisy
um that lined up right on top of each
other and it just
it was astoundingly good we had no idea
if there would be realization
you know there was a really good chance
it would all be completely washed up by
realization and we always thought you
know
maybe for some reason
the university
but probably you know it's important to
measurement to make just in case
anything
um you know but it turned out to be the
experiments turned out to be much better
than I thought and the agreement of the
the theory with the model is again much
better than I ever expected you know we
see a power law
over three decades
you see a spectral index which is close
to but not exactly equal to one you know
if it was exactly equal to one suppose
you know it was 2023 we had a plank we
had W map we had accurate spt and all
the data said that N Sub s is equal to
1.00 plus or minus 0.01 I don't know if
we would still be thinking about fish we
just say well you know that's a scale of
various factors that's what you expect
but deflation is a physical model and it
predicts that it's not exactly equal to
one if predictions close to one but not
exactly the one so that you know when
that started emerging to me that was
remarkable
uh and now we have measurements of the
mass distribution from lensing again we
were writing papers about this years ago
but if you know when it actually
happened it was spectacular I think the
status of inflation is that the you know
it was a great idea 30 years ago one
that should have been taken seriously 30
years ago but I think it's a you know
it's harder to disregard it much much
harder to disregard it now than it was
yeah 30 years
well Mark uh you've been so generous
with your time and
and uh your attention uh all these many
years to little old me I can't resist to
do what I do with all my guests that
honor me by coming on the podcast and
ask you just two existential questions
we have time for two of my patented
fantastic final four and the first one
I'm going to ask you about uh they're
both related to Sir Arthur C Clarke and
the first one has to do with his famous
statement that any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic and the way I like to kind of put
a spin on it the Keating spin on it is
to ask you What discovery in all of
science maybe just in your local neck of
the woods of science would you most want
to kind of trump it to the universe and
something that will endure as a
byproduct of the magic of of science and
technology that human beings or you have
created and sort of uh give us a little
Swagger for all humankind
[Music]
for science
from science yeah I thought I'll I'll
give you a minute to think but Feynman
who is Sean Carroll's uh previous office
uh occupant at Caltech he said the most
astonishing thing in the in the shortest
fewest amount of words is the atomic
hypothesis so that everything's made of
atoms so I wonder from your perspective
what is the most astonishing thing about
the that humans have discovered about
the universe about science
anything
I don't know I think
this cosmological model that we have
is pretty remarkable
um I think that's a Confluence of a
number of things
um you know ideas in theory but also the
technology that allows us to make the
measurements but it's also a product of
the fact that the Universe has
cooperated
um you know as I said the the
fluctuation amplitude is small which
means that we can treat the
perturbations with simple calculations
um and you know the universe is very
very close to isotropic and homogeneous
and turns out it's a very simple
Universe you would have never you know
if someone 150 years ago told you
that look in the next 150 years people
are going to understand
the largest scale structure of the
universe you wouldn't have expected that
the thing would have turned out to be so
simple
yeah that's right so we got lucky you
know with the the with the cooperation
you know through a collaboration of
Theory technological advancements you
know really bold and talented
experimentalists like
you know you and people that you work
with and have worked with
um
and the cooperation of the universe we
assemble this incredible model so we can
you know say with some confidence what
was going on you know just a few seconds
after the big bang
the standard model of elementary
particle theory
pretty remarkable that's a
to me I've been teaching Quantum field
theory for a couple of years now
and every year I've tried something a
little bit different so that I keep
learning
and it's a it's a mathematical structure
of quantum field theory is absolutely
remarkable
um so Mark with that I want to ask one
final question also kind of uh provoked
by Sir Arthur C Clarke he said a lot of
fun things that are really enjoyable to
whip out at faculty meetings such as for
every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert uh but one of his quips
I want to uh lay on you right now is our
final question and then we'll wrap up uh
and that is when a elderly but
distinguished scientist says something
is possible
he or she is most likely right
but when he or she says something is
impossible
they're most likely wrong now I'm not
calling you elderly and you're only a
couple years older than me I think uh
but you're distinguished I don't ask you
in that context what have you changed
your mind about what have you been wrong
about if anything
[Music]
oh I've been wrong about Lots
it's kind of interesting though
I think you know having
let's see I've been I started as a
professor
28 years ago
um and I had certain Notions about how
things work and how scientists work
um that I now realize are completely
wrong I had Notions about how they
graduate students should be trained 30
years ago that are in my Notions about
how they should be trained are
completely different
um
a quick example give me a quick example
how how have you changed what's
something you changed with regard to
graduate education
I think I was a you know when I first
started at Columbia I was a probably a
real hard ass about all the classes that
students need to take and all those
things technical things that they need
to master before they can really be
successful in research
and they still think that all those
technical skills in Mastery are
important but I now my you know now I
think that the most important thing that
graduate students do is get involved in
research as soon as they get into
graduate school
I mean if it happens with anybody who's
ever had a graduate student you have a
graduate student that come in the first
date they don't know anything they don't
know why this guy is blue they don't
know why the grass is green they don't
know you know where to find their office
they don't know anything they can't they
don't you know how to do not attack
anything
um and you know within three years like
you're like sitting across the desk for
them for like you know talking about
what they're working on and you realize
they're like explaining things to you
that you never thought about and it
doesn't happen because you're like
sitting there like giving them lectures
and saying do this problem do this
problem do this problem then come back
and show me your Solutions
I don't do that but uh yeah the most
important it's like you know teaching
people to swim
you know when I was a kid take swimming
lessons we stood at the they have a
stand to the side of the pool and
perfect our Strokes
you know they give us free feedback yeah
that's good that's good that's how you
do it and perfect the stroke and then I
get the water and it goes completely
worthless
that's right and uh theory and practice
are very different well Mark I want to
thank you so much personally uh for
being such a just a mentor a friend I I
always think you know when I hear some
crazy idea what would Mark think and and
it's not always the sober voice of
reason that you often provided me in my
career but it was the encouragement to
do things like come up with you know how
we would actually do bicep and and see
it through the fruition and now to see
22 years later you know bicep array is
still operating at the South Pole and we
have a hundred and you know 10 million
dollar project called the Simons
Observatory which features three you
know basic uh direct descendants of
bicep type ideas which Trace themselves
back to your paper with uh your
colleagues Andrew Jeffy good friend and
lemon Wang uh but that's just one of
many ways you've influenced me
personally you don't have to respond you
don't have to rebut this uh but I want
to thank you on behalf of my audience
and and me in particular and I hope
we'll get to see each other soon out
there in balmy Baltimore or out here in
sunny San Diego
well thanks to you from actually making
bicep happen for making polar bear
happen for making sandwich Observatory
happen
uh as I said you know
science and physics is mathematical
models for experiment results of
experiments and observations and so
there's really no point to anything that
I would ever do without all the things
that you and your colleagues are doing
oh thank you Mark have a great day I'm
not just saying that I know I know
you're not you're not uh the sunshine in
roses type uh Mark thanks again
yep it was great talk with you
foreign
[Music]